- Kicks family,
welcome back,
OK?
Welcome to the season
finale of "Sneaker Swap,”
the debate show where we argue a lot.
I've got my usual suspects with me:
Jeff Johnson, C.J. Toledano, Christian Pierre.
How are we doin’, guys?
I know it's the season finale,
but we're gonna send it off with a blast.
- Oh, I'm ready to argue.
I'm ready to argue.
I ain't gonna hold you.
- Jeff was on Google all last night
gettin' ready with the research.
- “How to win debates in under 10 minutes.”
- All right, guys, the topic for today,
tough one,
all right?
If you had the original
Bred 1 and Concord 11, would
you trade it for the Bred 4
and White Cement 3s?
Let's argue.
- You want me to go?
- I mean, you guys are all actin'
real shy right now.
- I’m gettin’ nervous. OK.
- It's the last one. We bein’ polite as hell,
you know?
I mean, C.J., you wanna set it off?
- Yeah, I'll set it off.
I mean, it's simple.
These are all classics, but I
think I would keep my Bred 1s
and my Concord 11s.
I just—these to me are
the most significant
of the Jordan line, like the
Banned. I mean, the Breds are,
you know, it's the Banned 1s.
Those are the ones where, like, you know,
the X over the Jordans in the commercial
and people were like, they went crazy.
Like, it literally flipped a
permanent switch in consumers'
heads that now we are
arguing about sneakers for a show that
people are watching, you know? Like,
that's the reason we are here.
That's the “Back to the Future” moment that
we gotta make sure happens for us all
to be here arguing against each other.
And then the Concords are,
you know, this is the ‘95,
this is the ‘95, ‘96
championship Bulls sneaker. Like,
we talk about Jordan's comeback.
Like, yes, he wore the 10s, but it
was the 11s that were like, “He's
back.” And the patent leather,
I mean, again, started
a whole ‘nother movement.
No one thought you could
put that material on sneakers.
It was a dress shoe for the court, and
only Jordan could introduce that and, yeah, I mean,
so these two shoes are hard to beat.
And so that's why I gotta keep
these. I would not trade ‘em
for those 3s and 4s.
- Yo, y’all are bein’ awfully nice today.
- I'll go for it. I'll go for it. For me,
if it wasn't for the 3s,
there wouldn't be the 4s.
There wouldn't be any 6s,
11s or anything. Like, you
guys remember, MJ almost dipped.
He almost left Nike to
go to Adidas at that time.
And if it wasn't for some dude
named Tinker Hatfield, a man
actually listening to what MJ wanted
on his shoe—like, actually
listening to what he wants
and putting it into his shoe,
there wouldn't be any of that.
So, you know, just thinking about
all that, mid-top shoe, rare at that
time in basketball. Everything was,
like, high-tops around that time.
And, like, let's not forget,
I think the 3s were the first
shoes that had a Jumpman logo on it.
Like, that was the beginning
of the Jumpman logo.
So there's that.
And obviously everybody loved
the 1s. Can't go wrong there, and
they had the big swoosh on the side.
Now, the 2s, I think they
removed the swoosh as well, but,
like, they finally decided to put
the swoosh on the back of the
heel, the whole Nike Air thing.
So, like, that was the beginning of Nike Air.
I think the 3 had
so many moments in it.
So I just gotta go with the 3s and
the 4s here.
- Investigative reporter
Christian Pierre breakin’ it down,
all of the news related to
Nike and Jordan and Bred.
Y'all said I did research.
He did RESEARCH research.
There's a difference.
It's double. But, you know, since y’all
be pulling out kicks and whatnot
on the show,
I'm pulling out my 11
Concords, and they're worn.
You see the oxidation. And these,
like, this is prom couture right here.
Like, this is what you wear when, you
know, you wanna have, you have the flicks
up. You flickin’ up at the prom, and
also, we talkin’ about the culture.
These Jordan 11s and “Space Jam,”
It's not too much that really needs to
be said. And I'm not gonna front,
I was going back and forth between
1 and 11, 3 and 4s.
Although I say I don't wear 4s,
I do own a pair of Bred 4s
because they’re just fly like that.
So I had to cop ‘em. And I love the
3 colorways too, but I think for
me, those 1s are the tiebreaker.
They have multiple pairs.
They just look really
dope as black and red.
And they set the standard
for what we have today,
just like what C.J. was saying before.
And when it comes to wearability,
for me, speaking for myself, I
think for me, I can wear 1s.
a lot of places. 11s, yeah, it's a
little bit more restricted, but because
of those Bred 1s and the fact that
they’re just so iconic,
I don't think I would trade them for the
3s and 4s, regardless of the fact
that I might own a couple of them already.
I don't think I would. I don't
think I would trade ‘em because
those, the 11s are my favorite
pair of Jordans and my favorite
silhouette. And those Breds.
are just too iconic.
They have too much
prestige for me to give up.
- I'm really loving the
beginning of this discussion.
I just wanna quickly add, I think
I'm gonna go Bred 1s,
Concord 11s. Beginning of
the legacy and then defining the legacy,
you know? That's it for
me, and Jeff, I'm with you.
11s are my favorite. I bought some
Bred 11s back in 2012 and I
never, I never stepped back
since. The Jordan 3,
it's just built differently,
honestly. Like, that shoe is
built for everything, you know?
Do I wanna hoop, do I wanna
step out, go to the grocery store,
or do I wanna run through the mud
and then I could clean ‘em off and it's
gonna come back lookin’ like brand new?
What do you guys think?
- Yeah, I mean, for me, it's like the ones
that we had mentioned, like the 1s, 3s
and 4s, to me, they look better worn.
- Yeah.
- They look better a little beat-up.
Like, when I got some OG 1s, I was, like,
throwin’ ‘em against the pavement
on the first day. I was like, “I
want these to look close to OG.
They can't look crisp.” But
the 11s, I'm like, “Oh, I
get two wears out of these,
and then they go back in the box
or back in the case.” Like, that’s
the tough thing about the 11s.
And I know a lot of people,
despite them, you know, being
like one of the most popular for
the common people, but yeah,
with a lot of true sneakerheads,
it's tough because you wanna, you
want your sneakers to get better
with age, and the 11s don’t do that.
- I feel like just the hype for the 11s
every holiday just gets
super old for me now.
Like, it's always these
same three or four pairs.
Every single time, it’s the Space Jams,
Concords, Breds.
I think this is one of the first
years it's, like, a new version
of the 11s coming out,
right?
And, like, they're not even that
great.
So, like, 11s,
they're a little overhyped
for me. Love ‘em.
Like, they're still cool.
They're great.
But, like, I think that's what
brings it down for this, for me,
in this trade to be honest with you.
- The 11s aren't sneakers that
you should wear every single day.
I keep a row.
Like, I don't think you should
wear them every single day, but I
do think they take a little bit
of extra upkeep. But I don't
think it's so much.
I think if they want to retro it
every year or bring out a pair
every year, then they need to start
experimenting with the colorways.
I agree with you on that.
But I think for the OG
colorways, it holds up.
- What about, what about
the comeback of OG
Jordan 4 colorways? We just saw the Fire
Reds are supposed to be releasing soon.
You guys excited for those?
- Oh, I'm big here for it.
I'm here for it.
I dunno. Fire Reds are one of those shoes,
for some reason, that always escaped me on
the 4s that I always wanted to get.
So, I'm definitely here for that.
I think, I think the White
Cement 4s dropping again also, so,
like, that's coming out again.
So, like, I'm here for all of those.
I think they dropped recently
too. Like, maybe two, three years
ago, but I'm not mad at them
4s are my favorite, probably,
Jordan silhouette also in general.
So, you know.
- This is the first
time we're getting the Fire Reds
without the Spike logo on ‘em,
right?
Or am I wrong?
- I think you're right.
- Oh, I didn’t even think
about that.
- But, like, yeah.
Cuz those Fire Reds are like—we
talk about we want Bulls colorways.
We want that classic colorway.
And I always feel like the Fire
Reds are, like, the closest like that.
If we're goin’ really matchy,
like, those are the Jordans.
And I remember the last time
those came out, I felt like
the Mars logo was on ‘em.
So it'll be nice to have
those in its truest form.
- Yeah.
- One thing that is weird
about the Fire Red 4s is that
they're changing the name, like, to
Tech Red or some shit like that.
- Right, yeah.
I don't know what that's about, but
in general, they’re still coming back,
so that's still kind of fire.
- It's probably
a different shade of red.
Like, legit. Or they created it, or
it's, like, 0.5 hues lighter
or darker than the original Fire Red.
It’s just like you give a color a new name,
and it's like, “Yo, it’s different.”
- Yeah, I don’t know if—
is it a legal thing?
Cuz again, they do that with, like,
the Columbias or Legend Blues
or, like, you know?
- Yes, yes, yes.
- I don’t—yeah, I wonder if this is like, if they do
comparison, if it's truly the same
red. I mean, it looks to me like
the Fire Reds in the picture though.
- Right.
We saw OG colorways before the
Fire Reds coming back and all that.
But I think the reason why I like
the 4s so much, especially in this
matchup, is because I feel like also,
like, obviously this is OG colors
you're talking about, but even post-OG
colors of the collaborations
that come out with the 4s, with this
matchup—it’s only
between the 4s and the 1s
to be honest. Like, the
4s have, to me, the best collabs.
Like, you have, what,
the Eminem, Travis Scott,
Doernbecher, Wahlburgers.
You got, like, a whole bunch of 4 collabs.
- Undefeateds.
- Undefeated, Off-White, Unions just passed.
Like, all these collabs
are just heat. For the
4s, they never miss.
And I even mentioned Mars Blackmon
obviously earlier, but, like, that also
speaks to the cultural, the cultural
relevance of the 4s when—
what’s the movie, is it “Do the Right
Thing” when he had the 4s also?
So, like, that had, like, a bigger
moment than just on-court.
It kinda spoke outside of that.
So, yeah, those are just iconic, bro.
- Yeah, the 3s are the—we talk,
we're, like, in this business, again, because
it's the intersection of sports and pop
culture. And, you know, the 4s in
“Do the Right Thing” and Spike as
Mars Blackmon and all the commercials.
Like, that was the beginning of it
all, I felt like.
- Fact. That's a fact. And Christian
is 100 percent right.
I think the 4s are the ones
that have out of, out of the
four that we're talking about,
the 4s are the ones that have the most
collaborations. And I'm surprised with
how iconic the 11s and
the 3s are in the culture that
people don't collab on them more. Maybe
they’re just like, “Yo, I like the colorways.
I like ‘em.
We don't want anymore.”
The amount
of Jordan 4 collabs that are out, right?
The amount versus what we see.
I don't think there's ever
been an 11 collab with any
artist, any celeb, any designer,
not that I remember. If I'm wrong,
I'm wrong, but I don't remember them.
I would’ve, I probably would’ve
copped if I did, right? 3s,
while there may have been
some collabs,
it's not as much as the
4s. Like, Christian ran off,
like, seven off the top of his head,
right?
Like, I think there's opportunities there.
And maybe that's what the future is.
Russ is about to drop a 16,
based off his biker jacket style
and a Con, a Converse Chuck Taylor,
based off of that. That's what I
think it should be in the future.
Like, if you're gonna, you don't have
to run back your same retros all the time.
All you gotta do is just run
with, just collab with somebody
and do something different.
- Yo, now that I'm really thinking about it,
the Jordan 11, you know, of 1 through
13, Is the only one that still has
really most of its OG colorways and just
one or two spinoffs. Of 1 through 13,
1 has a lot of collabs.
2 has collabs.
3 has collabs.
4 has collabs. 5 has
a lot of collabs. 6—
wow.
6 is untouched.
- Travis, there’s Travis.
- Well, there’s—you said 6s,
right?
There's Travis. 7s, touched.
8s, touched. 9s, touched. 10s,
no 11s, 12 and 13 and 14, now 16.
So, I don't know.
Maybe the 11s are off the market,
bro.
That could be it.
- They should just, like, give it more
to the athletes, because if you really think
about it, the Derek Jeter 11s are, like,
one of the most highly sought-after 11s, and,
like, the price for those is crazy.
So, I mean, I don't know if other
players would, like, tarnish it at all, but
Jeter’s 11s are crazy, so.
- And even the cleats. Like, having them
in cleats in baseball. A lot of the Jordan
Brand athletes wear Jordan 11 cleats.
So maybe that's what it is, that
innovation isn't so much in a designer;
it's the athletes that use them.
- The shoes that we're talking about,
like, the 1s—well, at least
for, like, the Sneaker Swap. It’s, like,
1s, 3s, 4s and 11s, right?
It’s crazy how all those
shoes—1s, 3s and 4s—
all have moments in them that
don't revolve in the championship.
And we still, like, cherish
those shoes in general.
Like, the 11s are the one—like, I
think he wore the Bred 11s in the Finals,
right?
So, like, those are the only ones—
- It’s, like, ‘95, ‘96.
- Yeah.
Those are the ones he won a chip in.
So, like, it's crazy that all those
shoes still have moments, whether it's,
like, gold chain MJ with the 1s, like,
Slam Dunk Contest, All-Star Games.
Like, as all those moments, you know?
So, that's pretty fire.
- I mean, we've made up—like, Jordan
Brand and fans have made up moments.
Like, we've had 6s where it
was called, like, SNL Jacket. Like,
“Saturday Night Live” Jacket 6s.
And it's like—
- Flu Games.
- That's a moment?
Yeah,
Flu Games. But like, yeah,
we're like, “Rookie of the Year
is his brown suede jacket.”
But, like, I just checked those out
on the consignment sites,
and they’re through the roof again.
And it’s just like, I was clownin’
‘em when they were coming out.
- Cuz Ja Morant wore ‘em
all of a sudden.
- Yeah.